so how was your trip then
i was it was fine the least stressful
thing going on my life is honestly the
surgery
i'm not really yeah honestly it sounds
crazy but
i'm actually looking forward to having
an excuse for people
like oh don't bother them with work
stuff like because i don't get that
excuse unless it's something like this
honestly i wouldn't i wouldn't be upset
if uh if they overdid the anesthesia and
i was in a coma for a couple weeks i'd
be like
nice rest some time off
they can be in position one second and
then it can switch
but um
no we were gonna name them uh heath and
heather just because my mom can't
pronounce h
or th just to break just to bust your
chops
but i think i think the girl might be
charlotte because we like the nickname
charlie for a girl
and then i like the name magnus for the
boy but
i don't know we'll see we also hillary
liked to evander
but the problem with that is it becomes
evan and the only heaven i knew was it
i can't do that this way normally for me
that's some of that is water you know
kind of the number one thing that can
happen
just like with your knee with the
effusion is you'll get fluid around the
lungs
that has to and just like a knee you
know they have to put a needle in and
drain the fluid around
the lung and so that can happen whether
you leave the tube in or not
but if if there's a lot coming out we
just leave the tube an extra day and
keep you an extra day in the hospital so
we'll just kind of see how that
how that turns out the ones up higher we
actually drill and we put
a tie through the sternum and so it's
almost impossible to move those upper
bars
the one that i worry about a little bit
on you is this lower one
which is your most important bar you
need a bar down here
right to pull all of this out because
this is where your problem is
so the bar is not sitting under bone
it's it's sitting under
you know a little bit of cartilage i
mean if you think about an earring how
easy it is to rip out an earring
it doesn't take much you could take this
movement and also it just ripped a
little bit
right and that three millimeters makes a
big difference you know normally it's
like
two months and we're like go we're gonna
be two months okay really carefully
slowly i don't want you starting to
bench for us and do stuff like
that you're going to be slowly starting
to do stuff you'll be right
i'm not worried about you okay it's
pretty tough i think you'll
watch then i'll get out and come out
from outside
yeah you'll be right i mean it's it's
not like it's fun
no
i guess i'm going to go in for surgery
and i'm going to stick a uh
a rod up my pee hole stephen crowder
oh powder hi how are you doing today
i underestimate your muscle oh let me
get the bigger one
give you bigger socks than my size
okay are you a youtuber
uh yeah we can say that ish that's part
of what i do
it's a weird feeling what that was a
weird feeling
just all the time yeah this means my
bare ass is hanging it's just always
weird
like when else do you have your whole
front covered okay and in your own words
what are we doing for you today
you're making me super chest hey brad
smith nice to meet you i'm an
anesthesiologist to be working with you
today oh
you're the guy who takes me just above
death we walked those fine lines very
closely but
we've got a whole team just working for
you today as you know okay
okay i don't like the roller coaster
thing
so given paying someone 90 dollars for
the day to make me feel like i'm
don't going to i say that filipino are
good-looking people it is racist but in
a good way
and oh my gosh asian babies like them
bill little baby
they look like dolls i know they look
like it's just
we have these ugly white people babies
stop it
wow he got for me 400 of celebrates
eight of decadron
40 of protonics
600 of gabapentin and 5 000 of heparin
there's two evans
and a gram of tylenol for you back there
guys before you will
we'll see you quick prayer with oh yes
please please take your time
we're praying to moloch remembering
representatives
[Laughter]
lots of equipment
that was the stuff i gave you oh i'm not
asleep
no it affects everyone differently and
people aren't usually
just asleep start sneaking a little more
stuff in your id
what are you sneaking fentanyl that's
the stuff that kills everybody who do
cocaine
i know but how'd you know yeah it's
inappropriate
one of my one of my co-hosts is a
recovering
alcoholic an addict and he was like he's
for him he said i stopped doing cocaine
when fentanyl became a problem
i really do appreciate oh look at how
healthy you guys have been
and i said it's because you know that
going to canadian hospitals when i was
raised they were very scary
so big z practice event
i'm doing great can you open up your
eyes really big for us bud
open up your eyes really big
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you look at mr crowder from the
outside he doesn't have a super obvious
defect but from the inside
this bone is causing the right ventricle
of the heart
to be smashed inward and losing quite a
bit of blood flow
[Music]
everyone gets a trans esophageal
echocardiogram
they have an echo probe that goes down
into the esophagus
and we can see the full dimension of the
heart
so you can see three bars in now
rv's well expanded lv function looks
good there's no pericardial diffusion
great you're all done with surgery it's
about three o'clock in the afternoon
there
[Music]
[Applause]
for some reason the tv the stations
wouldn't work except for paramount
so i watched the marvel universe
marathon
which doesn't interest me at all and
then the yellowstone
kevin costner marathon which interested
me slightly more
but then there was the bar rescue which
that's kind of fun so talk to me about
pain
okay so the pain comes from well first
off it's
all the time in my back and what does
that mean you feel like
sharp spasms
um well right now it's more like a seven
or eight because i haven't taken
the volume at all and then the other
pain is like internally
in my chest if i breathe deeply or if i
hiccup yeah or cough okay zero to ten
what number we're gonna do
like an eight okay like a seven or eight
broken femur is ten so call it a seven
okay these numbers on the inside of the
spirometer are excellent
so okay you're heading in the right
direction i have your travel card
to be honest i've only had one person
tell me that they've actually set off a
metal detector before
i just want just one which is odd but
with titanium rods yep my belt buckle
sets it off
and titanium rods i can't explain it i
haven't
i'm just gonna go through security with
a titanium sword
you are now on physical restriction
that means no lifting pushing pulling
upper body
more than five to ten pounds until
further notice
got it now is that actually my shoulder
or something wrong with my lungs
what kind of i don't know she said my
lungs looked weird but she
wasn't anything to worry about
hey john listen i just got a call from
stephen he says he's
he can't breathe he feels like he's
drowning and he can't call out to you
and you're not picking up i just got off
the phone with the 24-hour people at
mayo
they say get him to an emergency right
away all right so get him up
get him in the car and get him out to
the hospital get into the yard